violence Gore and oh so much nudity
plenty of ways to get an R rating but
who knew all it takes to get on the
mpaa's bad side is a little magic and an
F-bomb or two
written and directed by John Hughes the
1985 teen drama The Breakfast Club Stars
five members of Hollywood's so-called
Rat Pack Anthony Michael Hall Molly
Ringwald Emilio Estevez Judd Nelson and
Ali Sheedy set at a fictional High
School the story revolves around a group
of students from different walks of life
who seemingly share nothing in common
other than the fact that they've all
been assigned Saturday morning detention
there we meet angry malcontent Bender
morose recluse Allison cocky jock Andrew
awkward nerdy Brian and snobby Claire
over the course of the film The Five
Misfits Muse over the struggles in their
vastly different lives and they each
come to understand each other a little
better it's a tender heartfelt
coming-of-age story with few equals in
its day sadly it earned itself an R
rating thanks to its Frank discussion of
sex and drugs some crude language plus a
scene where they get high together smoke
that's what it is but while edging for
the 80s The Breakfast Club isn't
Actually All That explicit using
suggestive euphemisms more often than
not and while some mild drug use may
have riled parents in 1985. it hardly
seems all that R-rated today
written and directed by Cameron Crowe
Almost Famous is inspired by the
filmmaker's own unique life story
paralleling his days as a teen
journalist for Rolling Stone the film
follows 15 year old William Miller who
worms his way into the inner circle of
an up-and-coming rock group called
Stillwater along with alluring Bohemian
groupie Penny Lane William joins the
band on tour going on a journey of
self-discovery as he learns about life
love and friendship a touching story of
a young man looking to find his own path
Almost Famous got its R rating thanks to
some of the usual swear words and drug
use
well it might have crossed the line
however was a single personal nude scene
where Penny Lane is briefly seen dancing
with her shirt hanging open but take
that out and what you're left with is
both a rather subdued story where most
of the sex and drugs are only implied
and with none of the raucous antics you
might expect from a more wild and crazy
rock and roll biopic given its poignant
story of youthful rebellion and the
moral lessons it pedals seems almost a
crime that its target audience was kept
out of theaters by its own rating
an absolutely iconic buddy comedy
Blazing Saddles is a 1974 Western
classic starring Gene Wilder and Cleavon
Little as a pair of mismatched Partners
in the old west written and directed by
Mel Brooks and puts little into the role
of Bart a black laborer who becomes the
new sheriff of Rock Ridge but Bart has
only given the job because the corrupt
Governor hopes it will prompt the
townsfolk to flee allowing a railroad to
dismantle the town when markets went to
the plan though he recruits local Outlaw
Jim to help him stop the governor's
dastardly scheme a major hit Blazing
Saddles pulled in a whopping 119 million
dollars at the box office thanks to the
chemistry of its star pair and a
side-splitting script from Brooks a
wildly successful movie among critics
too it's been hailed as one of the best
comedies of all time and even earned
itself four stars from Roger Ebert but
despite its success we're forced to
wonder how much more popular it might
have been had it not received an R
rating mostly because it doesn't deserve
it sure in 1974 some of the more vulgar
jokes may have offended up tight types
thank you
foreign
looking back though it wouldn't earn
that rating today as much of what
crossed the line at the time is more
veiled humor and innuendo than anything
explicit
when it comes to action movies it can be
fairly easy for a tame flick to just
barely cross the line and earn an R
rating in the case of Constantine we
don't suspect it was the violence blood
or death that got at a stricter label
but its overall tone and dark themes the
film centers on the eponymous John
Constantine who has been sent to hell
but is back on Earth where he fights for
righteousness hunting demons and fallen
angels in an effort to Stave off his
Souls delivery to Lucifer the movie has
some fantasy violence and there are a
few Grim moments but the overall tone is
often rather tongue-in-cheek
nevertheless it's the Demonic nature of
the story that is most likely to blame
for its harsh rating the MPAA cautioned
viewers that the film contained violence
and demonic images but the violence
hardly seems any worse than your
standard PG-13 Blockbuster and while
hellish visuals may be cause for concern
for more devout religious vote it might
not even register as harsh for anyone
else
it's certainly not a surprise to learn
that one of the most popular horror
movies of the 2010s is rated R but when
you actually sit down to watch The
Conjuring the 2013 Ghost Story by
director James Wan you might be
surprised to find it's really not that
shocking at all the film tells the story
of a pair of Supernatural experts played
by Patrick Wilson and Biro Farmiga who
were brought in to investigate a
potential haunting at a remote Farmhouse
given the R rating by the MPAA for
Terror it seems it was the overall
spooky vibe that wrinkled the labeling
agency rather than any explicit
Bloodshed or even disturbing visuals
because frankly the film isn't really
all that violent and according to Juan
that was by Design as he held out hope
of the film making it out with the PG-13
rating in an effort to attract a wire
audience but as the film's producer
Walter Hamada told fans during an
appearance at WonderCon not long before
its release the MPAA had told him they
were stuck with a stricter rating he
explained it's just so scary there are
no specific scenes or tone you could
take out to get PG-13
it seems like critically acclaimed
coming-of-age stories can often fall
victim to the R rating despite it not
being warranted that might be because
Being Earnest and true to life sometimes
means showing young often underage
characters acting crudely and vulgar or
engaging in taboo activities like sex
and drugs as they navigate their way
into adulthood such as the case with
comedian Bo Burnham's full-length
directorial debut 8th grade which
introduces us to Kayla day an ordinary
middle schooler struggling with stress
at school and at home as she prepares to
graduate the titular year of school
aimed at an audience of teens the film
was a tender and heartbreaking look at
adolescence and was praised by critics
and young audiences for its realistic
depiction of growing up in modern
America it was in there
just sorry to my hopes and dreams
unfortunately thanks to some pervasive
profanity and a couple of suggestive
moments the film garnered an R rating
preventing kids who might relate to it
from seeing it in the theater on their
own of course this effectively cut them
out from seeing it at all as we're not
sure any 15 year old wants to be going
to the movies with their parents
a watershed movie from 1999 that mixed
sci-fi in action the Matrix
revolutionized both genres with
groundbreaking special effects and a
mind-bending immersive story and how
audiences questioning reality itself
full of dazzling visuals that included
the Innovative bullet time effect the
film's mix of rapid-fire martial arts
moves and Breakneck guns blazing
shootouts had the audience's jaws on the
floor the film follows Neo a young
hacker played by Keanu Reeves who's
recruited by Lawrence Fishburne's
enigmatic Morpheus and learns that the
world as he knows it is merely a
constructed reality and he is the key to
saving mankind exploring deeply
philosophical issues like fate versus
Free Will and the nature of identity The
Matrix captivated moviegoers like few
films ever had but with plenty of
violence including loads of hot leads
sprayed like water and shootouts that
left dozens dead this is one film that
might not come as a surprise to learn
was rated R but watch the film with a
more Discerning Eye and you might start
to rethink everything you thought you
knew about it because on closer
inspection you'll notice that most of
the violence is almost entirely
bloodless and the victims all simulate
with a few minor tweaks The Matrix could
probably have snagged a PG-13 rating
spun out of a series of impromptu
performances from Saturday Night Live
the 1980 film The Blues Brothers is
directed by John Landis and stars John
Belushi and Dan Aykroyd they put on
fedoras suits and shades to become Jake
and Elwood Blues a pair of musically
inclined ex-cons who find themselves
clashing with police a gang of neo-nazis
a rival music group and a crazed killer
all while trying to save a Catholic
orphanage from going under to complete
their mission from God the Blues
Brothers need to raise five thousand
dollars which they plan to do by putting
on a musical showcase and must recruit
other musicians to make it happen with
very little violence The Blues Brothers
is much more like a classic 80s Caper
and Buddy comedy than any kind of Island
action movie you might expect would
warrant an R rating but indeed that's
just the rating it received owed almost
entirely to its generous use of swear
words
take it easy
and while that did necessitate the
harder rating the movie was a big hit
anyway and the sensors seemed to get it
right the next time around because the
bladed sequel Blues Brothers 2000 was
handed a PG-13 rating in 1998.
the craft was a Pioneer in the sub-genre
of Supernatural teen dramas led by a
foursome of troubled young women imbued
with otherworldly Powers starring Robin
Tunney peruza balk Nev Campbell and
Rachel true the film's mix of coming of
age story and dark supernatural horror
may have been a poor choice if they were
looking for a PG-13 rating combining
those two elements may have been what
doomed it to the hard R rating much to
the Chagrin of younger teens although
the film did still manage to be a hit at
the box office admittedly there are a
few moments in the craft that could have
rightfully warranted its label there are
a couple of deaths that border on
graphic as well as a scene where one of
the young women is the target of a
failed sexual assault but it's not that
far from most of the PG-13 Thrillers
you'd see today sure there are some
crude language and vague discussion of
sex and drugs though almost none of it
is shown on screen well it might have
pushed it over the edge however is a
wrist slashing scene that includes
plenty of blood it's a disturbing
sequence that some audiences might
understandably want to be cautioned
against but considering that the 2020
sequel to craft Legacy wasn't much
different and garnered a PG-13 it makes
one wonder if the originals are was a
bit of a reach
and what might be one of the most
egregious examples of a movie being
given a harder rating than it deserved
the 2010 drama The King's Speech was
slapped with an R for one simple reason
too many F words but the use of
profanity wasn't gratuitous or
unmotivated and was actually a key
component in the story of the life of
England's King George VI who suffered
from a debilitating speech impediment
set in the 1930s The King's Speech is
the remarkable true story of the real
Prince Albert who was faced with a
terrifying prospective giving a national
speech on his Ascension to King after
his brother abdicates the throne the
Crux of the story centers on his
treatment for a stammer with the help of
speech therapist Lionel Logue log log is
able to help Albert with some unorthodox
methods and eventually makes a
realization that swearing can help Abate
Albert stutter and it's an al-famous
scene that led to the film's r-rating as
Albert lets loose a torrent of comical
obscenities in a session with Logue back
up
oh yes
fortunately because of its importance to
the story the swearing is not a
superficial element that can be easily
excised to get a lighter rating but no
matter because the film went on to win
critical Acclaim on route to capturing
the Academy Award for best picture and
earning its lead Colin Firth an Oscar
for best actor
foreign
[Music]